Cuando hablamos de Texas puede que nos
vengan a la cabeza cosas como los western
la música country,  George Bush o cierto
Ranger...
Sin embargo, este estado es mucho más
que toda esa serie de clichés.
Texas ha sido durante los últimos años
uno de los motores más importantes de
la economía de Estados Unidos.
En este vídeo te lo contamos.
Con una superficie de setecientos mil
kilómetros cuadrados, equivalente a 1,5
veces España, Texas es el segundo estado
más grande de los Estados Unidos, sólo
por detrás de Alaska. Está situado en la
región sur conocida como el "sun belt",
parte del estado está bañado por el
Golfo de México y hace frontera
precisamente con México teniendo ésta
una longitud de más de 2.000
kilómetros.
El estado de la estrella solitaria puede
llegar a ser una tierra verdaderamente
arida y hostil. De hecho Texas cuenta con
un clima formado por cuatro peculiares
estaciones: la estación de la sequía, la de
las inundaciones, la de las ventiscas y
la de los tornados.
Todo ello no ha sido impedimento para
que Texas se haya convertido en la décimo
segunda potencia económica del mundo, ni
para que sea el estado que más crece,
que más empleo genera y que más
exporta de los Estados Unidos. Desde el
año 2000 su población ha crecido
en seis millones de personas, más que la
de ningún otro estado, y más de un millón
y medio de estadounidenses se han
trasladado a esta tierra en busca de
futuro.
De hecho Texas se ha convertido dentro de
estados unidos en aquel lugar que para
muchos fue América hace siglos.
El lugar donde acudir en busca de un
nuevo comienzo, de una nueva oportunidad.
El lugar al que trasladarse
cuando uno se ha quedado sin trabajo o
no encuentra el camino. Así, según los
datos publicados por el censo
estadounidense,
cinco de las ocho ciudades que más
habitantes ganaron durante 2015 son
tejanas: Houston, San Antonio, Austin y
Dallas.
"Como anécdota, personalmente el caso de
Dallas no me sorprende.
Es una de mis ciudades preferidas de
Estados Unidos, es tranquila, ordenada
y tiene un encanto bastante especial."
Pero volviendo a Tejas ¿Sabías que cerca
del 40 por ciento de los 27 millones y
medio de habitantes que tiene Texas son
de origen latino? Pues, no sólo eso sino
que se calcula que para una fecha tan
próxima como el 2020, la población
hispana se convertirá en la población
mayoritaria de Tejas, haciendo de este
estado, para pesadilla de personajes como
Donald Trump, en la segunda mayor potencia
hispana del mundo después de California,
donde los hispanos ya son mayoría.
- "Yo amo a Greg Abbott como yerno,  y
como gobernador
los texanos también lo amarán." En lo que
llevamos del siglo veintiuno, Texas ha
liderado la creación de empleo en
Estados Unidos. Desde el año 2000 el
empleo en Texas ha crecido tres veces
más que en el resto los Estados Unidos.
Por ejemplo, en el mismo período
Texas creó prácticamente un millón de
puestos de trabajo más que California a
pesar de tener 12 millones menos de
habitantes. Desde que comenzase la crisis
financiera en diciembre 2007, Texas, que
representa poco más del 8 por ciento de
la población de los Estados Unidos, ha
sido responsable de uno de cada cuatro
empleos creados en todo el país.
Por supuesto el paro lleva siendo más
bajo que la media nacional desde hace
diez años. De la misma forma, en este mismo
periodo de tiempo, el pib del estado del
Ranger Walker ha crecido un 60 por
ciento frente al 35 del resto del país.
Además, como decía antes, es el estado
que más exporta y 52 de las empresas
del fortune 500, las mayores del país,
tienen su sede aquí.
Por todo ello, no es extraño que cada
vez más personas consideren que Texas es la
auténtica locomotora de los Estados Unidos.
Y aunque este año la economía texana
se está resintiendo como consecuencia
de la caída del petróleo,
pocos dudan de que este estado
mantendrá su pujanza gracias a que su
economía está cada vez más diversificada.
Llegados a este punto la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es ¿que pasa en Texas?
Para los trabajadores de ingresos medios
y bajos la mayor ventaja de Texas
está en la vivienda, pudiendo acceder a
casas grandes y asequibles. Y es que
Texas es uno de los estados donde
la regulación urbanística es más laxa,
de tal forma que es fácil construir y
el precio de las viviendas no diverge
sustancialmente de su coste de
producción.
Así, entre 2001 y 2008, el condado de
Harris, que incluye a Houston, autorizó
doscientas mil nuevas viviendas frente a
las pocas más de 16.000 que se
autorizaron en el condado de Santa Clara en
California, uno de los estados más
restrictivos. En el condado de Santa Clara se
encuentra, por cierto, Silicon Valley.
Una vivienda nueva cada dos hectáreas en
Texas frente a una vivienda nueva cada 20
en California. Es decir, que en Texas,
aunque ganes menos dinero, vas a poder
acceder a mejores viviendas que en el
resto de Estados Unidos.
Texas ha logrado desarrollar uno de los
mejores sistemas universitarios del mundo. A
pesar de contar con poco más de 27
millones de habitantes, cuatro de sus
universidades están entre las 100
primeras del mundo.
España, por ejemplo, un país mucho más
grande, no cuenta con ninguna universidad
situada entre las 100 mejores del mundo. Este
sistema universitario no sólo genera
profesionales altamente cualificados y
mucha investigación alta calidad sino
que también atrae las inversiones de
muchas empresas de alto valor añadido.
Es uno de los estados donde más rinden
los salarios gracias a que el nivel de
precios es inferior al de otros estados,
a que las viviendas son más asequibles y a
que los impuestos son más bajos.
De hecho, Texas es uno de los 7 estado sin
impuesto estatal sobre la renta y, teniendo
en cuenta todos los impuestos estatales
y locales, es el quinto con menor
presión fiscal.
Una familia media puede ahorrarse más
de 3.500 dólares anuales respecto a si viviese
en el estado de Nueva York.
En general, se considera que el estado
tejano es el quinto donde más rinden
los salarios.
Además, la economía texana está
considerada como una de las más libres
de los estados unidos - la quinta
según el instituto Fraser - y donde, por
tanto, más fácil resulta emprender
nuevos negocios.
Evitar regulaciones tan cuestionables como requerir  a
un diseñador de interiores 2.190 horas
de formación y pasar un examen para
poder ejercer como ocurre en Nevada,
Lousiana o Florida, han hecho de Texas un
lugar atractivo para invertir.
Gracias a ello los millennials  prefieren
Houston para emprender en vez de otras
ciudades como Nueva York o Boston.
Cada vez son más los estadounidenses
que piensan que el país entero debería
parecerse más a Texas, y es que frente a
la imagen de ser un estado de cowboys,
su amplia  diversidad étnica y cultural
está logrando que ciudades como Austin
sean ya consideradas un referente para
músicos y artistas de todo tipo
El caso de Texas nos muestra que es
posible combatir con éxito los efectos
negativos que sobre el empleo tienen la
globalización y la automatización de
procesos. Y no lo ha hecho
tratando de proteger a sus empresas de la
competencia exterior sino tratando de
de incordiar lo menos posible a
sus empresas y ciudadanos.
- "Cada semana muchas empresas dejan california
para huir de los altos impuestos y las
asfixiantes regulaciones y se trasladan a
Texas porque mantenemos impuestos bajos
y regulaciones razonables." Y vosotros
¿qué pensáis? ¿Seguirán más estados la
senda iniciada por Texas? ¿Podría el efecto
Trump convertir a este histórico estado
republicano en demócrata para 2020? Y
tú, ¿te imaginas viviendo en Texas?
Esperamos como siempre vuestros
comentarios y  si te ha gustado el vídeo
dale a like  y suscríbete al cana si
aún no lo has hecho ¡que es gratis!